[Music]
that's right here's how it works
we found some of our studio audience
members so interesting so inspiring we
were moved to write songs about you alan
let's find our first subject
[Music]
granola and weed in his cargo pants if
you try the night he do the hacky sack
dance
very nice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we thought he was a skater we thought he
was a punk but he took us to his car and
he opened up the trunk and there inside
were porcelain
you saw unicorn
door-to-door
[Applause]
who's next
[Music]
scrabble to be
shimmy pops
to hell
shimmy sky new room
she's the
lady who was hard to write a lyrics form
[Applause]
so
who's next
[Music]
hey
it's daniel day lewis preparing for his
role as the dallas mavericks jerk
[Applause]
next
[Music]
hey he's got tons of friends a cool job
great kids and a wife
[Music]
but he's also got a filthy tattoo that
could destroy his life
we wanted to tell you what it is but the
network firmly said no no no no
ah screw it it's hitler blowing out
[Applause]
teach that guy to come to this show all
right